talk about a little bit about the
movement snacks these are developed by a
friend of ours Julie Angel who comes
from a parkour background Julie's
actually a filmmaker who started to film
parkour athletes and as an observer she
realized oh they've got some really kind
of cool
natural movement skills that a lot of
people could benefit from so she
extracted movement snacks from the
isolated movements of Parkour athletes
like Precision jumping or quadrupedal
movement right traveling around on all
fours yeah yeah but that kind of thing
too to balance on your left foot and
your right hand at the same time and
move forward and then she realized these
are fun they are non-threatening and
that if you do a little bit of bear
crawl for like 30 seconds and you stand
up Everything feels loosened to the
parkour Community will form a big circle
as a way of saying hello and then they
will bear a crawl to the center and
everyone will high five and then they'll
reverse and bear crawl backwards back
out that's the warm-up but they've now
extended their entire chain of motion
and they're ready to go out and work out